why don't we go next to Jacob from
Denver Jacob from Denver welcome to the
David packman show what's on your mind
today well
yeah you're on the air
cool I just have a question about
um hypocrisy so I've been following your
channel now for a long time and it's
it's all over the Internet it's all over
news this idea that you know someone's
being hypocritical it's like is it even
valuable to point out hypocrisy anymore
well politics more in general or is it
just is it a fallacy it's not a fallacy
no it's it's not a fallacy to point out
hypocrisy it helps us to get at sort of
the root of what elected officials
really care about right like for example
if an official claims to care about the
deficit when a Democrat is president but
not when a republican is President it
suggests to us they don't really care
about the deficit they care about
scoring political points and then it
allows us to maybe more accurately
assess and evaluate the things that they
say so in that sense it's not fallacious
you are getting at a reality though with
which is not only have Republican
elected officials clearly stopped trying
to avoid the appearance of hypocrisy and
double standards their voters also don't
seem to care so there is a question
about the utility of us pointing out
right-wing hypocrisy when the elected
officials don't care and their voters
don't seem to care is it just a waste of
time I think that that's a perfectly
fair question to ask
yeah I agree I I I do I do feel that
itch there should be some sort of value
behind it yeah but it's almost like a
fatigue at this point it's like how much
longer can anybody stand watching
anybody call somebody else a hypocrite
it just it feels so vapid at this point
a hundred percent it does it shouldn't
but it does because consistency has been
abandoned even as a goal and that's
really the sad part
yeah all right man thanks for the call
all right yep uh Jacob from Denver great
to hear from you